c'est quoi en gros la caq bakhat l'acca
l'acca le cac black jack la caq la
coalition avenir québec c'est le parti
au pouvoir depuis quatre ans et celui
que gérer la pandémie c'est le parti
dirigé par françois legault un ancien
homme d'affaires ses 76 des 125 députés
à l'assemblée nationale et c'est aux
partis fondés en 2011 que met fin à des
décennies d'alternance entre le parti
libéral et le parti québécois laquelle
ce parti qui se dit nationaliste qui met
sur l'économie et sur la défense de
l'autonomie du québec par exemple sa
langue et sa culture fromage en grains
fromage en creux dommage oui oui comme
vous appuyez sur fromage le boulot
pendant son mandat le gouvernement
khakis a adopté la loi sur la laïcité
qui empêchent certains employés de
l'état de porter des signes religieux au
travail là aussi réformer la charte de
la langue française sont bulls était de
mieux la protéger et il a voulu durcir
les politiques d'immigration provincial
le gouvernement le gorille est aussi
investi pour favoriser l'autonomie
alimentaire et yeux créer un tribunal
spécialisé en matière de violences
sexuelles et conjugales en environnement
laquelle a été lue avec une plateforme
électorale qui étaient jugés pas très
prometteuse par des groupes
environnementalistes mais pendant son
mandat le gouvernement le goût à adopter
une loi pour arrêter la recherche et la
production d'hydrocarbures et a fait une
stratégie sur l'hydrogène verts et les
bioénergies c'est quoi en gros le parti
libéral parti libéral parti libéral du
québec parti libéral parti libéral du
québec du parti libéral du québec le
parti libéral du québec le parti libéral
c'est le plus ancien parti au québec ça
a été fondée en 1868 et c'est celui qui
a été le plus souvent au pouvoir
d'ailleurs c'est le parti qui formaient
le gouvernement avant la cac avant les
élections c'est l opposition officielle
avec 27 députés sur 120 5 à l'assemblée
nationale et sa chef c'est dominique
anglade une ingénieure et ancienne femme
d'affaires
[Musique]
le parti libéral c'est un parti qui veut
mettre de l'avant le développement
économique et la défense des libertés
individuelles
par exemple les libertés des minorités
linguistiques et culturels c'est aussi
un parti fédéraliste donc qui veut que
le québec restant le canada aujourd'hui
les libéraux de dominique anglade sans
vouloir se rapprocher de la classe
moyenne une leurs propositions et de
baisser les impôts pour la classe
moyenne et de les augmenter pour les
plus riches
les libéraux ont aussi dénoncé la loi 21
sur la laïcité et veulent rétablir le
droit des enseignants à porter des
signes religieux comme le voile en
environnement les libéraux proposent un
virage vert de l'économie en développant
l'hydrogène et comme tous les partis ils
veulent améliorer la situation dans le
système de santé par exemple en mettant
fin au temps supplémentaire obligatoire
c'est quoi en gros québec solidaire
québec solidaire québec soldats québec
solidaire québec solidaire québec
solidaire québec solidaire c'était le
deuxième groupe d'opposition à québec
avant les élections c'est que 10 des 125
députés à l'assemblée nationale c'est un
parti fondé en 2006 et c'est un parti
que deux qu'on porte parole maintenant
c'est une militante féministe et gabriel
nadeau dubois qui était un des leaders
de la grève des étudiants de 2012 si le
parti est élu c'est lui qui va être
premier ministre
[Musique]
québec solidaire un parti qui veut
défendre l'égalité et la justice sociale
le parti cdu de gauche féministe
écologiste démocrate et altermondialiste
ça c'est un mouvement qui critique le
modèle de mondialisation actuelle pour
l'europe puisse entrer sur le main et
l'environnement québec solidaire est
aussi pour que le québec se sépare du
canada la crise du logement était un des
chevaux de bataille de québec solidaire
dans les dernières années le parti
propose par exemple d'instaurer un
contrôle pour limiter la hausse des
loyers dans le passé québec solidaire
s'est aussi opposé à des projets
d'exploitation d'hydrocarbures la partie
entre autres bilité contre l' usine de
gaz liquéfié gnl québec qui a finalement
été rejetée par le gouvernement le parti
veut aussi permettre un meilleur accès
aux soins en santé mentale par exemple
en embauchant beaucoup de psychologues
dans le réseau public c'est quoi en gros
le parti québécois quantique
parti québécois et le parti québécois
québécois le parti québécois parti
québécois le parti québécois c'était le
troisième groupe d'opposition avant les
élections c'était celle des 125 députés
à l'assemblée nationale
c'est un parti fondé en 1968 qui est à
l'origine des deux référendums pour
faire du québec un pays le parti a été
en alternance au pouvoir avec le parti
libéral mais en ce moment c'est plus
difficile son chef s'est passé car
plamondon qui est avocat de formation
s'il choisit
la raison d'être du parti québécois
depuis sa création c'est de faire du
québec un pays le parti a toujours voulu
lutter pour protéger le français et
l'identité québécoise il définit ses
valeurs comme étant le nationalisme la
justice l'équité la liberté et la
protection de l'environnement pour te
donner une idée le parti québécois veut
aller encore plus loin pour protéger
français et mettre en place un plan qui
ferait en sorte que plus de personnes
utiliseraient le français dans la
province le système de santé est aussi
dans la ligne de mire du parti qui
propose une série de mesures pour le
redresser par exemple de prolonger les
heures d'ouverture des blocs opératoires
des hôpitaux et des cliniques et pour
les péquistes la protection de
l'environnement savons main dans la main
avec la création d'un pays
pour lui ça permettrait au québec de
prendre toutes les décisions
environnementales qu'il concerne le
parti propose aussi l'accès illimité aux
transports en commun pour un dollar par
jour pour faire en sorte que les gens
l'utilisent plus c'est quoi en gros le
parti conservateur du québec parti
conservateur parti conservateur du
québec parce qu'on savatage parti
conservateur ce qui aidait les partis
conservateurs c'est un parti créé en
2009 mais qui a attiré l'attention plus
récemment avec la pandémie et depuis qu
éric duhaime un ancien animateur de
radio est devenu son chef en 2021
mais a noté que des jeux un parti
conservateur au pouvoir dans les années
1800 au québec pour en revenir au
présent le parti conservateur actuel a
fait son entrée à l'assemblée nationale
en 2021 lorsqu'une député de la kek est
passé de la caq au parti conservateur le
parti avait donc un député sur 125 à
l'assemblée nationale le parti
conservateur dit vouloir surtout donner
plus de liberté ou québécois il dit
vouloir éviter d'empiéter sur les
libertés individuelles et sur le libre
marché ça veut dire qu'il veut une
économie avec le moindre est possible
pendant la pandémie de covè 19 le parti
conservateur était contre les mesures
sanitaires en ce moment une de ses
priorités c'est de développer une
économie qui favorise la concurrence par
exemple augmenter le nombre
d'entreprises privées dans ce système de
santé pour justement créé une certaine
concurrence le parti a l'intention de
permettre à nouveau l'exploration des
hydrocarbures qui a été aboli par la cac
les conservateurs veulent aussi limiter
les taxes et les impôts des
contribuables
par exemple il veut diminuer les impôts
des travailleurs qui gomme plus de 80
mille dollars par année n'y a jamais eu
autant partis politiques qui ont
participé à une élection dans l'histoire
du québec en plus des partis principaux
ya aussi plein de partis ont des plus
connus c'est le parti vert du québec en
partie écosocialiste social principe qui
peut pas y avoir de progrès social sans
respect de l'environnement le parti est
aussi fédéraliste dont tu préfères
québec reste du canada sa mission est de
protéger l'environnement et de réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
par exemple avec la gratuité du
transport en commun il ya aussi le bloc
potes qui comptait entre autres la
hausse de l'âge légal pour consommer du
cannabis à 21 ans le parti 51 qui veut
faire du québec le 51e état des états
unis et le parti culinaire québec qui
veut favoriser l'agriculture et le
développement durable ce que le parti
appelle une gastronome cratie ya aussi
des petits nouveaux comme crime au
québec le parti de l'ancien chef du bloc
québécois martin ouellette party animals
québec pour le bien-être des animaux et
quelques partis associés à la mouvance
conspirationnistes comme québec est
écrite et il ya toujours l'option de
voter pour un candidat indépendant c'est
à dire un candidat qui est affilié à
aucun parti politique est cité standort
sont tellement haut que la seule
personne à qui tu donnerais tu ont voté
notre sélection nationale perd fâche que
des gens qui décident d'annuler leurs
potes en cochant toutes les causes ou
aucune cost sur leur bulletin de vote